this lesson will cover cuprates cuprates
our organometallic reagents with unique
reactivity Kubb rates can be made from
other organometallic reagents alkyl
lithium's like this propyl lithium here
can be reacted with copper iodide this
generates the cuprate and a molecule of
lithium iodide salt notice that two of
the alkyl groups become associated with
the copper when making the cuprate so
we'll need two equivalence of this
starting material now this is a great
reaction when you can buy your alkyl
lithium or maybe generate it in one step
but when you're synthesizing a more
complex reagent in the lab that perhaps
you want to convert into a cuprate you
probably don't want to go this route
there ends up being two alkyl groups on
here but only one is transferred in the
reaction so if your material is a little
bit more precious you might want to
generate your cuprate from a grignard so
to synthesize this you probably made the
corresponding bromide treated it with
magnesium metal and dry ether and got
this reagent now say you want it to have
the reactivity of a cuprate and not a
grignard reagent treating this grignard
reagent with catalytic amounts of copper
iodide will create a cuprate in situ
your reaction flasks okay now we know
how to make these but why would we want
to make these let's look at the unique
reactions that cuprates can perform
cuprates participate in cross coupling
reactions in this reaction the copper
can insert itself into this carbon
bromine bond the copper eliminates
itself and basically we get these two
pieces stitched together this reaction
retains the geometry at the alkene and
allows us to form a carbon-carbon bond
now this doesn't have to contain an
alkene we can use a lot of alkyl halides
in this cross coupling reaction and it's
important to note that if you treat an
alkyl halide with a grignard reagent
you're going to have elimination
since happening not this cool reaction
where the pieces come together so that's
one way that coupe rates are unique from
grignard reagents the cross coupling
reaction even works with acid chlorides
these two pieces will combine and the
group from our cooperate replaces the
chlorine on the acid chloride now
remember that grignard is an alkyl
lithium reagents nucleophilically attack
at carbonyls and we would never really
want to react them with an acid chloride
because acid chlorides are way too
reactive anyway so we would expect
nucleophilic attack if we did that
reaction but here instead the carbonyl
stays intact we can replace the chlorine
with this group smoothly and in good
yield cuprates like organolithium and
grignard reagents can be used to open up
oxides just like the other
organometallic reagents the cuprate
attacks at the least sterically hindered
carbon atom opening up the Epoque side
and the arrow pushing looks like this
this produces an alkoxide that can be
treated with water in an aqueous workup
to give the alcohol the final reaction I
want to tell you about is conjugate
addition this molecule in a known has a
carbonyl in conjugation with a double
bond now let's review the reaction that
would happen when we treat this with a
grignard reagent or an alkyl lithium
when we treat this with butyl lithium
the carbonyl will be attacked producing
an alkoxide and we can add in a second
step and aqueous workup to protonate
that and make an alcohol so the final
compound has the double bond intact and
has added a butyl group to the carbonyl
converting it into an alcohol but
cuprates do something very different
cuprates instead do conjugate addition
or one for addition they attack at this
terminal carbon at the end of the
conjugated system the arrow pushing
looks like this
so our cooperate has added here this
double bond has shifted over and we push
the electrons up onto oxygen this
compound is protonated and reforms the
ketone and one way to show the arrow
pushing is like this
now the reason we see this difference is
because alkyl lithium's and grignard
reagents they have a lot of ionic
character in the bond and so we have
like a c- and it's got a counter ion
it's balanced with that lithium but the
bond here has very little covalent
character has quite a lot of ionic
character and so it's going to be
attracted to the carbonyl because the
carbonyl has this dipole that puts a
delta minus on the oxygen and a delta
plus on the carbon so this addition is
governed by ionic interactions with this
dipole here whereas the cuprate has a
lot less ionic character it has more
covalent character in this carbon copper
bond so this reaction is actually
governed by orbital overlaps so we get
good orbital interactions with this soft
nucleophile at this terminal carbon atom
the differences in reactivity here are
pretty cool we can actually react butyl
lithium or a corresponding grignard
reagent and have it attack at the
carbonyl leaving the double bond intact
if we use the cuprate we lose our double
bond but still have our carbonyl to sum
up cuprates our organometallic reagents
that can be made from other
organometallic reagents they have unique
reactivity where they can take alkyl
halides and couple them with another
alkyl piece forming carbon-carbon bonds
like alkyl lithium's and grignard
reagents they can open up oxides at the
least hindered side producing alcohols
and finally with in owns they have
completely different reactivity adding
at this terminal carbon of the
conjugated system instead of at the
carbonyl KP here if you learn something
give me a thumbs up on the way out and
for more chemistry subscribe to my
channel